merci en début de semaine nous avons eu
le discours se réalise de trump soho
l'union avec son lot de critiques et
date at admin m et j'ai vraiment
regretté l'absence de réaction commune
des institutions européennes et puis
elle nous avons eu dix scouts theresa
may sur le break site qui au moins a eu
le mérite de la clarté ce contexte il
nous oblige il nous oblige à aller de
l'avant
ils nous obligent à une refondation de
l'europe pour une europe plus unie plus
forte plus politique qui saura se faire
respecter dans le monde
une europe en capacité de produire de la
croissance durable et du progrès social
une europe en capacité d'assumer sa
propre défense
une europe en capacité d'apporter les
bonnes réponses aux défis du monde
migration développement climat
terrorisme c'est à ces rendez vous là à
ce rendez vous là de la refondation de
l'europe que nous sommes désormais
attendue par nos concitoyens je vous
remercie